[Música]
realmente vencimos al desierto yo creo
que es una frase que la mayoría de los
que estamos aquí hemos escuchado en
algún momento el desierto está ahí
existiendo en silencio con un clima
extremo pero a la vez le puede abrir los
brazos a cualquiera que aprenda a vivir
en él es un acorde es un ecosistema con
vida aferrándose a él día con día
evolucionando adaptándose y sobre todo
resistiendo
nosotros como seres humanos solíamos
vivir en armonía con la naturaleza
éramos parte de un ciclo porque
entendíamos que sin la naturaleza no es
posible sobrevivir
pero hoy en día hemos roto ese vínculo
no salimos de este ciclo porque quisimos
acelerar el paso y hacer las cosas a
nuestra manera
y actuamos de una manera totalmente
inconsciente
entonces si ya no sabemos coexistir con
la naturaleza merecemos ser parte de
ella
es que como laguneros a pesar de que
estamos en el desierto chihuahuense
vivimos en un desierto somos una región
privilegiada porque tenemos agua y tal
vez que suena irónico porque si algo
caracteriza a los desiertos es
precisamente la escasez de este recurso
pero aquí ocurría magia con el río nazas
y aguanaval pero entonces en esto que
nosotros llamamos progreso
decidimos regresarnos y ahí empezamos a
cambiar el sitio
nosotros cada año recibimos bastante
agua en nuestra región agua suficiente
para cubrir cada uno de los que estamos
aquí sino de toda la comarca lagunera
nuestras necesidades y que los mantos
acuíferos se regeneren y que pueda
continuar el ciclo de vida
pero entonces porque casi a diario
escuchamos ya no hay agua a la laguna
entonces dónde está esa agua o quién la
tiene la verdad es que hoy en día aquí a
nivel regional el agua se ha vuelto una
cuestión de privilegios y quién tiene
dinero y poder tiene acceso a ella y las
poblaciones vulnerables qué
que el caso del agua no es un derecho
humano y es que precisamente el problema
radica en que nuestro alto ego y en
nuestro sentir de guerreros invencibles
pensamos que vencimos al desierto por
desviar ríos por establecer actividades
económicas que en una región como ésta
cualquiera pensaría que nos podrían ser
prósperas y pensamos que vencimos al
desierto porque hoy en día aquí tenemos
uno de los rastros más grandes a nivel
latinoamérica e incluso a nivel mundial
y presumimos de que vencimos al desierto
porque somos la cuenca lechera más
grande del país en medio del desierto yo
solamente les quiero hacer una pregunta
y que lo analicen
ustedes creen que todas las miles de
personas de aquí de la región de ejidos
no nos vayamos tan lejos de aquí de
colonias del torreón de gómez y lerdo
que no tienen agua que tienen que
quedarse en la madrugada esperando una
pipa para poder surtirse de agua y bañar
a su hijo y mandarlo al día siguiente a
la escuela ustedes creen que esas
personas se sienten vencedores del
desierto o ustedes consideran que las
personas de lugares como finisterre o
algunos lugares de viesca que tienen
marcas en la piel por tanto arsénico que
están tomando de verdad consideran que
mencionan es cierto y es que si lo
analizamos desde otra perspectiva más
profunda nos daremos cuenta que no
solamente somos productores de carne y
de leche y de lácteos realmente somos
exportadores de agua y es muy ilógico
estar exportando agua desde un desierto
otra cosa es que el cambio climático es
real 100 real ahí está la evidencia
científica y si es nuestra culpa y aún
hay personas que dudan de él y sobre
todo la mayoría sigue sin tomarlo como
un problema serio
es un problema muy serio porque si la
temperatura del ambiente del planeta
sigue aumentando estos miles de millones
de años de evolución en la tierra se
acaban por unos cuantos siglos de
ambición la verdad es que la vida en el
planeta se ha visto en riesgo en
numerosas ocasiones ya sufrimos varias
extinciones masivas como en el cretácico
terciario cuando se acabaron los
dinosaurios o en el la otra extinción
masiva cuando se acabó el 70% de los
vertebrados terrestres y el 90% de la
vida marina
hay algo que es importante recalcar que
estas extinciones masivas ocurrieron por
factores externos
por objetos celestes de enorme tamaño
que colapsaron con la tierra no estaba
en las manos de nadie y hoy en día la
extinción masiva a la cual nos dirigimos
va a ser la primera vez que es
ocasionada por la vida misma en el
planeta por una sola especie por un solo
tipo de humanos realmente por llenar las
cuentas bancarias de unos pocos nombres
y a lo mejor estarán confundidos porque
vamos a vincular las ideas porque
empezamos hablando de desierto luego de
agua y ahora con el trilladísimo tema
del cambio climático y es que quiero
llegar al siguiente punto
que necesitamos
para mitigar el cambio climático para
lograr adaptarnos a él porque realmente
los daños que tenemos son irreversibles
pero aún podemos adaptarnos lo primero
es reducir urgentemente las emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero los
culpables de que se esté calentando el
planeta
pero la verdad es que tener 400.000
vacas lecheras y 300.000 vacas de
engorde más todo el otro ganado como
cabras ovejas más millones de aves de
corral en una sola región la verdad es
que no parece muy alineado con la meta
para el 2030 en 11 años tenemos que
hacer reducir al menos el 45 por ciento
o el 50 por ciento de estas emisiones
creo que podamos lograrlo
y un modelo económico que es ilógico y
fuera de que no es lógico ya no es
posible sostener porque el planeta y
nuestra región no puede tolerarlo es que
no es exageración de verdad es ilógico
que pretendamos invertir todos nuestros
recursos naturales en una sola actividad
económica como es la agropecuaria porque
esto tarde o temprano va a colapsar
y cuando esto pase cuando exista este
colapso ambiental ni siquiera este tipo
de actividades se van a poder hacer
porque sin agua no tenemos nada y sin
suelo fértil pero vamos a hacer
entonces precisamente es la originalidad
por actuar
hoy en día necesitamos que las empresas
sean más conscientes de lo que están
haciendo estas empresas y estas
compañías e incluso nosotros mismos
pensamos a un corto plazo un beneficio
monetario inmediato
las ganancias son muy buenas pero son
para pocos y el negocio es rentable pero
no para todos
realmente pocos se atreven a
cuestionarlo
y realmente hay muchos intereses de por
medio pero el interés por el medio
ambiente ni por la salud pública
nosotros le otorgamos la licencia a
estas empresas para contaminar
y por eso precisamente son socialmente
responsables
no son socialmente responsables
necesitamos ahora adaptar
tenemos mucha resistencia al cambio
creemos que no es posible cambiar esto y
aquí somos y de aquí no nos movemos hay
una resistencia enorme al cambio y en
algún momento ya habíamos cambiado
nuestro modelo económico porque pasamos
de ser un emporio del algodón y de la
uva a hacer un emporio de la carne y de
la leche porque no repensar la economía
y es que la verdad es que ya no es
opcional
esto es sí o sí porque estamos en una
emergencia climática hoy en día existen
muchas alternativas dentro de la
economía
como modelos de negocios enfocados a
cumplir los objetivos de desarrollo
sustentable que necesitamos para cumplir
estos acuerdos internacionales que nos
van a ayudar a combatir el cambio
climático necesitamos urgentemente
reducir estas emisiones y precisamente
cambiar este modelo de negocios
porque actualmente tenemos otros
opcionales como la economía circular
existen las finanzas sustentables que
nos permiten evaluar las inversiones no
solamente en la parte económica sino
agregando a otras cosas como estos
factores ambientales sociales y de
gobernanza por qué pasa esto porque
realmente los inversionistas se dieron
cuenta que también las compañías capital
está en riesgo ante el cambio climático
pero aquí no lo hemos entendido y
precisamente por eso es que necesitamos
actuar
hoy en día el concepto de
sustentabilidad aquí en la región es
sólo una palabra estamos muy lejos de
alcanzarlo y no estamos dando pasos
firmes para hacerlo el problema es que
el tiempo se acaba de verdad vale la
pena atacar un ecosistema por un
supuesto desarrollo económico porque la
verdad es que parece que ni siquiera ese
objetivo estamos cumpliendo y nos
decimos seres racionales pero ni
siquiera podemos discernir entre
progreso y peligro
necesitamos re asignarle un valor a las
cosas que valen más en el desierto
diamante o vaso de agua
nuestro antropocentrismo condenó y está
condenado a todas las especies del
planeta porque nos sentimos con el
derecho sobre la vida
hicimos de la vida una mercancía en un
producto mercantil izamos con la vida
hoy en día damos y quitamos la vida a
nuestro antojo y lo peor es que le
quitamos la vida a especies de una
manera muy cruel y ya no por cumplir el
rol de la cadena trófica sino por
admisión hoy en día estos animales no
son seres vivos son máquinas que entran
a un proceso productivo y mientras
sirven estas máquinas ahí están
pero cuando no se pueden reemplazar como
cualquier otra como si la vida fuera un
recurso inagotable hoy en día sabemos
las implicaciones que tiene lo que nos
ponemos lo que tenemos en la mano lo que
tenemos en la boca pero seguimos siendo
indiferentes quiero comer carme pero me
incomoda ver el proceso por el cual tuvo
que pasar para yo tener ese pedazo en mi
plata entonces cierro los ojos
y me hago cómplice hoy no hay nueve
primeros sino realmente hacerles una
invitación de que tenemos poco tiempo
pero estamos realmente a un paso de
poder alcanzar esto yo te digo a ti que
si hoy te movió algo salgas y hagas algo
no te quedes sentado de verdad todos
tenemos una voz que puede ser escuchada
hay muchas maneras de hacerlo y si no
sabes cómo hacerlo acércate a personas
que puedan ayudarte le atribuimos una
ponencia de activismo por ejemplo
no sé cómo va a intentar montar una
industria sino hacernos reflexionar cómo
podemos juntos salir de esto porque
alternativas tenemos muchas lo que
tenemos poco es voluntad de cambiar las
cosas la cuestión es que no podemos
seguir yendo incluso en este planeta no
podemos ir viéndonos de la naturaleza
sin servirla ella porque tarde o
temprano la naturaleza va a tomar el
mando y de hecho ya lo está haciendo
entonces está dando patadas a verte si
respondemos
yo considero que hoy tienen dos opciones
seguir indiferentes sentados
ante estas injusticias ambientales y
sociales o tomar la opción de alzar su
voz y me gustaría que fuéramos más los
que tomáramos la segunda opción
porque aún falta mucho por lograrlo
tenemos que vencer la indiferencia el
egoísmo el individualismo pero no
tenemos que vencer al desierto con el
desierto tenemos que aprender a vivir
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]